There are inherent differences in how men's and women's brains are wired and how they think.
I'm talking about animal research, brain imaging studies and cross-cultural surveys.
One tidbit from the article focused on a group of 34 rhesus monkeys.
Males liked toys with wheels instead of plush toys.
The females preferred the plush kind.
Same thing for human boys and girls on the 9 to 17 month range,...
...preferring stereotypically male versus stereotypically female toys.
Another study showed infant girls respond more to faces and start talking earlier.
And later in life, men are focused on things, women to faces.
Finally, navigation studies in humans and rats show females often rely on landmarks...
...while males calculate their position by estimating the direction and distance.